- Guys, it is Tuesday.
It's time for WeTweet.
Here we go, everybody.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to WeTweet.
This is where we --
we as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going to vote on
whether you like each one
or not.
Y'all have voting clickers
at your seats.
It's the biggest and the highest
in technology, right there.
Yeah. You can vote for them.
The green says you like it,
red says you don't like it.
Or you don't have to vote
if you feel like just
sitting back and relaxing.
It's up to you. We're going to
see the results live.
And, Higgins, Roots,
do you have clickers too?
-Got it.
-And whatever tweet gets
the most likes,
we're going to tweet it out
live during the show so that you
can all like it and WeTweet it.
[ Audience ohs ]
Alright, here we go.
You guys ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And remember, no standing
ovations in any of these.
-Really?
-Yeah, you just either
like them, you press them.
You can laugh.
Yeah, we like audible.
We like to hear
you laughing as Well --
-But don't stand up.
-Now we just heard
from the judges,
you're allowed to stand up.
-Oh, okay.
-Yeah, yeah.
Okay, the first tweet is...
♪♪
"Uh, sir. Sir, could you please
put your shirt on and...?"
"I appreciate that respect."
Here we go.
The results are in.
Let's see the votes.
No. No.
Didn't like it at all.
People were upset.
That upset people.
-Yeah.
-That bummed people out.
"Sir, I'm going to have to ask
you to leave for not voting."
[ Laughter ]
Alright,
this next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Stop looking at me.
Alright.
Let's see the results
on this one.
I think it's going to be better
than the first one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go!
That's the one. That's it.
Almost -- Almost got
one standing ovation.
-Really?
-One girl almost stood up.
-Almost stood up.
-She stopped herself
halfway through.
Yep. Alright.
How about this next one here?
It says...
[ Laughter ]
-Ha!
♪♪
-Deep cut.
-That's a deep cut.
That's for the deejays
out there.
Alright, I think --
-I think it's a good one.
-Yeah. But can it beat --
-No.
-No, I don't think
it's going to beat 157.
Quest, you don't think so,
right?
-It's good, though.
-It's good though, yeah.
Let's see the results.
Oh, wow!
-Wow.
Wow!
-Wow. Shocking.
-88 and full of hate.
-It got a sit--
sitting ovation, that one.
-Wow.
-Let's try the next one.
It says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow, that almost got one.
-Yeah. I think so.
-Acai!
-Can I vote twice?
Acai!
[ To tune of
"Dragostea Din Tei" ]
♪ Aca-ee, aca-eye ♪
♪ Aya-ee, aya-ah-ha ♪
[ Drum roll ]
Acai, let's see the results.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Cheering, laughing ]
♪♪
-Oh, my goodness!
Wow.
-Yeah.
Why would we even do
another one?
[ Laughter ]
You won't get better than that.
-We're not going to get --
we might.
-Well, we could get
much lower than the first.
-That's true.
-Let's see how low we can go.
[ Light laughter ]
Let's see
if the red clickers work,
just to make sure
it's not rigged.
'Cause that one, I think
that one should be the hit.
-Yeah, so you're saying
let's try on this one,
to everybody vote no
and see what happens.
-You can't tell everyone
what to do.
-Okay. You do whatever you want.
-But we can also prove
that the system is not rigged
by all voting "no" on this one.
-Right, sure. Right.
-And then you see
if it's rigged or not.
Although we could
edit it in post
and make the audience at home
think that we did this.
But I would never do that.
[ Laughter ]
-We could also edit in some
standing ovations too.
-Yeah. No, there hasn't been
one standing ovation at all.
We could vote "no" on this, and
then have a standing ovation.
-Vote "no" and standing ovation.
Yes!
-Alright. This might happen.
This has never happened.
We get zero of the votes, so
either don't vote or vote red.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Why are we going this?
-Keep it interesting.
-Last one is...
♪♪
-Oh, the humanity.
Wow.
I don't think
you had to even tell them.
-No, there's a couple people
I can tell voted "yes"
just to...
[ Laughter ]
Let's see the results.
Are we getting a standing ova--
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ] No!
No! It's no!
It's not absolutely no.
[ Laughs ]
I love it.
25 people voted yes.
There we go. We have a winner!
It's number four!
The one with acai.
[ Indistinct ]
I'm going to post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like.
Give it a WeTweet.
Thank you to the 25 people.